[Music]
Full Faith and confidence I think one of
the things that's so important and uh we
don't see this enough in these in
today's world is for someone to take
responsibility is for someone to
actually say I made a mistake and I take
full responsibility and I think that's
important here the motivation I'm not
going to speak I'm not going to speak to
that I'm going to speak to the action of
taking responsibility here and I think
that's important and the president
appreciates
that
wom and an Administration that have
never taken responsibility for anything
has told us that it's important to take
responsibility for things I'm Dave ruin
I'll be taking responsibility for
today's program this is the Ruben report
it's January 10th 2024 we're live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and locals
postgame show as always Ruben report.
locals.com but the theme despite my uh
let's say disdain for that woman at this
point the theme is consistent with what
she just said that taking responsibility
where your actions your actions and your
decisions uh is good it actually is good
and that if you realize that you have a
little skin in the game and that maybe
you can influence things then maybe you
actually can influence things wouldn't
that be something so that's what we're
going to be diving into today we're
going to start with a little bit of this
Jimmy Kimmel Aaron Rogers fight that we
talked about earlier in the week because
I think there's sort of a metaphor there
or a parable with the Trump and DeSantis
situation that there is a way that we
can beat the lying we can do the things
that we say we are going to do and we
just have to decide to make the right
choice and oh if you haven't been paying
attention that Iowa caucus is on Monday
so let's just dive right into it you
guys know about this Jimmy Kimmel Aaron
Rogers fight Aaron Rogers obviously
famous football player he's injured
right now play for the Jets Jimmy Kimmel
total hack corporate late night comic
they've been going back and forth uh
because Jimmy obviously was big on covid
vaccines Aaron roders was I would say
vaccine hesitant believed he was young
and healthy and a athlete Peak physical
condition didn't want to get the vaccine
so Jimmy Kimmel was always making fun of
him and making fun of probably people
like you watching this right now and all
the people who didn't want to get
vaccines or didn't want to just swallow
whatever it was that the government was
telling us uh anyway they've been going
back and forth Aaron Rogers implied that
maybe Jimmy Jimmy Kimmel had something
to do with Jeffrey Epstein uh and it
continued last night I'd be time to
revisit that concussion protocol Aon so
he saw that and maybe to retaliate he
decided to insinuate that I am a
pedophile this is how these nuts do it
now you don't like Trump you're a
pedophile it's their go-to moved and it
shows you how much they actually care
about pedophilia but here's the thing I
spent years doing sports I've seen guys
like him before Aaron roders has a very
high opinion of himself because he had
success on the football field he
believes himself to be an extraordinary
being he genuinely thinks that because
God gave him the ability to throw a ball
he's smarter than everyone else the idea
that his brain is just average is
unfathomable to him we learned during Co
somehow he knows more about science than
scientists a guy who went to Community
College then got into Cal on a football
scholarship and didn't graduate someone
who never spent a minute studying the
human body is an expert in the field of
Immunology he just put on a he put on a
magic helmet and that g made him a
genius
it's Aaron got two A's on his report
card they were both in the word Aaron
okay and can you
imagine that this hamster brained man
thinks he knows what the government is
up to because he's a quarterback doing
research on YouTube and listening to
podcast I looked it up this is actually
a thing it's called the Dunning Krueger
effect the Dunning Krueger effect is a
cognitive bias in which people with
limited competence in a particular
domain overestimate their abilities in
other words Aaron Rodgers is too
arrogant to know how ignorant he is it
is incredible when we show you these
clips and then I say these people only
need a mirror everything he just accused
Aaron Rogers of is exactly what he is
his inflated sense of selfworth and all
that he has 20 writers probably it might
be 30 writers 20 to 30 writers that are
highly paid Hollywood writers to make
him that funny and then he lectures
people every night instead of actually
entertaining them before they go to
sleep which was the whole point of late
night uh comedy by the way um Aaron
Rogers being skeptical of the vaccine
and the mandates and all that yeah that
was actually pretty wise and we know
about all the vaccine injured people and
the fact that the vaccine did not
actually stop you from getting covid nor
transmitting covid and all the stuff on
top of mandates and everything else but
okay so that's just a little squabble
and you might go okay why do we really
care about that but I want to now
connect this to something much larger
because here's just another 10 or 15
second clip of Jimmy Kimmel and I think
you'll see where we're going here the
truth still matters and when I do get
something wrong which happens on rare
occasions you know what I do I apologize
for it which is what Aaron Rogers should
do which is what a decent person would
do but I bet he won won't if he does you
know what I'll do I'll accept his
apology and move on but he probably
won't do that my guess is he won't
apologize I hope I'm oh that's
interesting Jimmy so decent people
apologize and you're not of you're not
above an apology because I don't
remember an apology for this Dr foui
said that if hospitals get any more
overcrowded they're going to have to
make some very tough choices about who
gets an ICU better I that choice doesn't
seem so tough to me vaccinated person
having a heart attack yes come right on
in we'll take care of you
unvaccinated guy who gobbled horse goo
rest in peace
Wheezy literally calling for the death
of the unvaccinated or at least for them
not to be treated as equals at a
hospital because they were hesitant over
an experimental vaccine that we now know
did not work so Jimmy Kimmel loves the
government he loves if the government
tells you something you better do it he
loves the pharmaceutical industry if
they want to inject you as something you
better do it and he's is really pissed
that a football player who went to
Community College actually got more of
this stuff right but Jimmy we'll we'll
take can we clip this we have the
ability to clip videos is that something
we can do we're going to clip this and
I'm going to Tweet it at you Jimmy
because an apology would be nice uh for
those people who just decided not to get
vacc and then actually were not treated
equally at hospitals and then we now
know that rates of cancer have jumped
because people were not going to
hospitals or were not admitted and a
series of other subsequent uh health
problems that people now have uh but
this drama continues and now I want to
show you how Okay so they're just
fighting you're going all right it's a
late night TV star fighting with a
football player we get it about covid
some people got it right some people got
it wrong uh but it actually leaks all
the way up into our political and and
media uh Stratosphere let's say here is
Aaron roders on the Pat McAfee show
going after Kimmel and then we'll show
you a CNN response to that you know
mentioned ior mechon being horse bace
and push that whole narrative for a long
time he gave a platform to one of the
biggest uh spreaders of misinformation
during the covid times Dr
fouchy um so in my opinion jeez you know
he RI me about RI me about the vax and
and that turns out to be an L on on many
occasions because the vax was not safe
and effective like we were told that it
was in the beginning uh there are a lot
of injuries now that we've seen related
to the vaccine so in my opinion you went
after me that's fine you're a comedian
go for it not offended but that was an L
putting everything I've discussed so far
aside this concept that what is
happening now on ESPN shows and on
Sports shows are constant debates over
vaccines and race and everything else
that's partly why Sports as a whole why
the MLB the NBA even NFL I think
although a little lesser extent to the
NFL that the ratings have collapsed on
all of these things because we are so
sidetracked from talking about sports
are watching people do exceptional
things on the field and the court and in
said we're always talking about the
political version of that but anyway
they're going back and forth on all of
this and now I want to connect it to the
to that wider Stratosphere I mentioned
uh here is CNN's Oliver Darcy now this
guy Oliver Darcy he has tried to cancel
me many times he's gone after Joe Rogan
he's just sort of like a stooge for the
machine he goes on CNN and he's like a
media Watchdog so he's sort of like
Brian stelter light I actually think he
used to occasionally sit in for stelter
uh and watch what he does here he he
lays the pressure into Disney because of
course Disney's connected to this too
because Disney owns ESPN and much like
they wreck Star Wars they W wrecked ESPN
uh here is CNN's media Watchdog Oliver
Darcy putting pressure on Disney to
basically fire Pat mcae who's the host
of that show that Aaron Rogers was on of
course what Rogers is saying there is is
just not true the medical community
would have course say that the vaccine
was both safe and effective and at some
point you have to wonder when ESPN and
its parent company Disney when they step
in here you know uh Disney's at this
point one of the only uh major media
companies outside maybe Fox News that
would would allow this sort of dangerous
uh
antivaccine medical misinformation to be
aired unchecked on their air and this
isn't the first time Rogers has done
this you know he goes on these extended
rant during his weekly appearance on the
Pat McAfee show which is aired on ESPN
but for now ESPN and Disney they're
they're staying silent and not
commenting what a little buge eyed freak
yes the vaccines are safe and effective
the medical community believes that the
vaccines are safe and effective and it's
only Disney owned ESPN that allows this
besides Fox you see what they're trying
to do this is exactly what they were
doing with Rogan a year and a half ago
when they were all trying to cancel
Rogan over the nword which he never said
pejoratively he was always saying to
make fun of the people who are the
actual racists what they do is they go
oh there is competition out there
people are tuning out of our nonsense
they're suddenly watching ESPN and
getting more sane political analysis
from Aaron roders than they're getting
here on our Network so we better put
pressure on Disney to fire Pat McAfee
for having that conversation we better
make sure the fox can't get any
advertisers because they're scary too
and by the way let me say it one more
time the vaccine is not safe and
effective and I thank the good Lord
every single day that I didn't get it
that guy didn't get it this guy didn't
get it that guy didn't get it the guy
back there didn't get it I wonder if my
Gardener got it I feel like he didn't
get it either he's pretty cool uh what's
the point of all of this guys if you
take responsibility for your actions as
Aaron Rogers is doing he's not telling
anybody how to live their life he was
just saying hey I'm young I'm healthy
I'm fit I I'm skeptical of this it
turned out to be right if you take
responsibility for your actions and you
have self-awareness you start actually
putting some order into the world and I
think we can actually connect that to
what's happening not only in this
Republican primary right now between
Trump and desandis but will what will
largely happen in the general election
that we're probably going to know the
candidates of uh pretty pretty quickly
Jimmy Kimmel doesn't seem to take
responsibility for his missteps I don't
think Donald Trump's done a great job
when it comes to taking responsibility
for his missteps I think Aaron roders
has right I think Ronda santis has but
we'll get there okay you'll you'll see I
promise let's talk about gravity fire
real quick guys I want to take you on a
journey behind the scenes of the shoe
industry where we'll uncover the stark
contrast between a premium shoe maker
and those simply riding on massive
advertising budgets buckle up as I
unravel the insights gained during this
eye-opening exploration enter G defy
shoes a true departure from the ordinary
backed by a groundbreaking clinical
study conducted by UCA now picture this
While others have clung to shoes
featuring a run-of-the-mill memory foam
soul for the past 5 decades GFI stands
apart with its patented and meticulously
designed Soul construction this isn't
just about absorbing shock it's like
your shoes giving you a high five with
every step boosting you forward and
adding a pep to your stroll GFI isn't
going for the easy way out they're not
just grabbing any old soulle off the
shelf nope they're on a mission to boost
the biomechanics of how shoes work and
fostering of movement that nurtures your
body now while other question the
adequacy of their Footwear G ifies in
the business of creating Miracles it's
not just a shoe it's an immersive
experience a device that alleviates pain
and serves as a natural Footwear to
preempt further wear and tear trust me
you want to be part of this
revolutionary journey and I'm thrilled
that I finally am G defy doesn't pour
Millions into celebrity and athlete
endorsements to entice you although you
might have spotted G defy on some famous
feet instead their investment is
channeled into the foundational
construction of the shoe but don't take
my word for it explore the multitude of
reviews and testimonials from ordinary
individuals who test to the miraculous
impact gy shoes have had on their lives
available on the gy website and social
platforms visit gy.com right now because
your feet deserve more than another pair
of shoes and here's a little extra love
for our listeners use the discount code
Ruben 30 for an extra $30 off your $150
or more order yes that's right G defy
your feet do it right now and now back
to me feel like that was a very intense
ad read I should get some kind do they
give kind of Golden Globe awards for
that kind of thing anywh who now let's
shift this to uh the political situation
because yes in about four or five days
Iowa finally has the caucus and then
primary season is upon us and it seems
fairly obvious to me that Ronda santis
the guy that I'm obviously backing and
is the governor of by far the best state
in the Union and the freest place on
planet Earth uh he pretty much needs a
win in Iowa I would say he either needs
a win or a very second second place uh a
close second let's say to Donald Trump
to continue after that and then of
course we get New Hampshire South
Carolina we enter super Tuesday all of
that kind of stuff anyway as we roll
into uh this Iowa caucus they are doing
a few more Town Halls CNN did one last
night and as usual Dan santis no
fireworks no no crazy rants or anything
else just clear calm answers that are
truthful will the people decide that
that's good enough I'm not so sure but
here's Dan santis answering a voter's
question on the border and how he would
do things differently than Donald Trump
we got another question from Jim he's an
engineering manager here in De Mo uh Jim
there you are Hey listen let me ask you
how how are you looking at this race
right now as you get ready to head to
the caucuses on Monday I'm looking
forward to it I think there's uh a lot
of good candidates I'm definitely
leaning towards Mr sanis but I have not
fully decided yet but uh you got a
question for the governor so go ahead I
do uh Donald Trump vowed to build the
wall yet only succeeded in building
about 50 miles Democrats use their
activist judges and bureaucracy to
obstruct the program how will you
address immigration and succeed where he
failed well thanks Jim and I I think
it's a huge issue uh because if we can't
get this right where we're a sovereign
country and you have millions and
millions of people coming from all over
the world uh I don't see how we're going
to be successful so I'm going to declare
a National Emergency on day one in
office I'm going to Marshall resources
including the military to stop The
Invasion when people come illegally uh
they need to be deported back to their
home country you know Donald Trump
promised uh record deportations he
actually deported less than Barack Obama
did in his first four years so he's
promising the same this time but he
didn't do it the first time around I
will do it because if you don't have a
sanction for coming illegally you're
going to continue to have the problem I
am going to build the wall now he said
build the wall to Mexico pay for it he's
actually been in Iowa and has reflected
on that promise and he said there was no
way he could have Mexico pay for it
they're not just going to give you money
there was no legal mechanism but you
know people criticized him in 16 for
they said you can't do it he said he
would do it I thought what he was going
to do and here's what I would do the way
you raise money for the wall you charge
fees on the remittances that workers
send to foreign
countries okay as always when you hear
something true your body doesn't feel
tight and contorted it's refreshing you
can sit up straight with your shoulders
back and go like oh that was true now
the reason that I believe Ronda santis
when he says I will declare a National
Emergency on day one and I will deploy
the military the border and I will do
the deportations is he has a long track
record of doing everything he said you
person watching this right now if you
can give me a laundry list of items
things that he has said that he was
going to do that he did not do or
outright lies I would love to hear him
but I actually believe that he would
would do that now will the people of
Iowa uh believe it do they believe it
will they vote that way we shall see uh
but here's just a quick clip of somebody
at that town hall basically saying they
were changing their mind on the Fly good
so you you told you said that you're
leaning towards former president Trump
is that still true or how are you
feeling
tonight I thought I was but I've heard a
lot of good stuff tonight so we'll see
all right who knows maybe people you
know it's it's very hard to see where
the people who can change their votes
are you know I always say how it's like
the one set of people right now that I
think at the general election that's
that really can move are those
disaffected liberals because they're
seeing what's going on with the
Democrats and the progressives and all
the nut nutty stuff over there and the
wokeness and all that and they might
move now I think most of them
Unfortunately they just won't vote for
Trump they just won't if he's the
nominee I actually do think they might
vote for DeSantis and I think it will
become more and more obvious that he is
not some crazy right-wing Maniac racist
blah blah blah all of the things that
people say about him I think the more
people see him they just see this kind
of decent guy what's what's like the
number one criticism of DeSantis right
now the the number one criticism seems
to be he's not enough of a showman he
isn't boisterous enough like he's just
coming off as a decent guy who's there
to do the job who is in the military
like who's done a nice job as Governor
young family all of that uh here was
just I'm just going to show you one more
from this it's just a nice moment uh
where a voter uh I think captures well
kind of what been trying to tell you I
believe when the Democrats vote for
Biden they're not voting for Biden uh
but they're voting against Trump and and
uh the same thing um if they're uh if
they're uh voting for Trump than they're
voting against Biden and and the reason
I asked Ron that question uh why he
wasn't going after Trump is because I
look at Ron as the only candidate that
can unite the country because because
look at it Trump gets elected half the
country is still going to be
divided and hopefully we don't you know
they don't go to any well speaking of
divided you you do have a question for
the government I do have one and uh but
I but I believe Ron can unite the
country we got to have somebody that we
can all stand behind Republican or
Democrat okay sir and he's the guy that
can do it what's your question thank you
okay Brett Bear was not having it you
know the lecture before the question but
the point there if we're going to get
past any of this it seems fairly obvious
to me that we need a leader who is
honest we need a president who is honest
who says what they're going to do and
then goes ahead and does it there's one
guy running right now that has that
track record there's several other
people running I would say on the
Democrat side and on the Republican side
that don't have a track record like that
they have a track record of failed
promises Andor outright lies or games or
anything else but imagine if DeSantis
was president and started doing the
right things at the border well yes
would the left be going nuts and they
would would the activists still be doing
their thing and antifa and BLM and the
Hamas people would they all be pissed of
course they would be but the average
person who was suddenly who's just like
a moderate Democrat and they do exist or
the average Republican that maybe
occasionally could vote either way they
might go you know this guy's actually
pretty decent I'm not going to make a
big deal about it I do like having a
border oh we've started deporting people
oh there's a little more Law and Order
oh he's empowered the states to do what
they think is right and we don't have
just this authoritarian layer telling
everyone what to do all the time like I
actually think it could work that it's
not that we're all going to be United
like we're all going to agree on all the
issues it's not like you get to day two
of a disantis presidency or anyone's
presidency and suddenly everyone's like
okay we we're all United on abortion no
that's never going to happen but if you
have someone up there that people can
look at and be like all right we
basically do know what he thinks and we
do know what his actions are the average
person not the activists not the Twitter
crazies I actually think could come
around and we could get something that
would roughly feel like a United Country
uh but yes I do also think that that
voter is right that a certain amount of
the Biden people are just voting
anti-trump and a certain amount of the
Trump people are just voting anti- Biden
and that is a problem although there's a
lot of reasons to be uh anti Biden
here's Biden himself uh well here he is
and it'll give you a good reason to
think that you should be anti- Biden
that's the America we're building
together instead of erasing history
we're making history so a home owned by
today a home owned by a black family on
one side of a highway built by the same
Builder on the other side of the highway
and a white guy living in it the white
guy's home is valued more than the black
guys no I know you know it but guess
what that that's how you build
generational wealth I know I know you
know it no you know what like he just
makes up some story right like I've
bought houses before uh often you don't
know who lives in the house before you
what color skin they are or anything
like it's just it's just endless also
we're making history they're erasing
history you guys are the ones that are
ripping down monuments these are
Democrats this is your base but even
putting aside the house thing and like
the specifics of real estate related to
race and everything it's like that they
want everything to be so race focused a
black person owns a home A white people
will be able to pay less for it it's
just endlessly divisive and that is what
the Democrat Party has right now right
they will just make you think that
everyone else is a bigot and a racist
and blah blah blah and by the way
there's the the sort of polar opposite
version of that coming out of trump all
of these people are pedophiles and
Communists and whatever now I would say
a portion of them are but there has to
be something between those two things uh
unfortunately one of the people not
between those two things is brainlet
AOC uh here she is uh well basically
explaining that Republicans are bad
because they're into impeachment
something that she was into for an awful
long time when there was a certain
orange man that was
president what they're using and what
they're doing is taking impeachment and
taking all of the most serious
procedures that we have as a country and
they're learning to use it for political
they're politically weaponizing it for
an election purpose for a political
purpose and in doing so they are putting
the people of this country everyday
Americans absolutely at the bottom of
the barrel and they're putting
themselves first it's a selfishness that
that really endangers this country it
endangers our electoral process it
endangers our legal process it's deeply
cynical and it's done to reelect
themselves and line their own pockets
all right as you know everything she
just said Republicans are doing is
exactly what Democrats did when Trump
was President right two impeachments
nobody even remembers what they were for
both of them failed obviously one of
them the the January 6th one he was
already leaving like he was on the way
out anyway just utterly pointless and
utter waste of time and money and brain
power and everything else and there's
not a lot of brain power with that woman
um so when she talks about Republicans
politically weaponizing things for their
own benefits it's the Democrats who
literally
right now as we speak who are trying to
remove Donald Trump off the ballot that
is I would say a mild case of political
weaponization do you think uh anyway
here's a bit more because as you know
when the Democrats don't get the way
they uh don't get things the way they
want them uh then they try to destroy
the institutions too uh here's a AOC on
well maybe just removing Clarence Thomas
from the Supreme Court so why do you
think he should he should recuse himself
I mean I think it it's very clear
Clarence Thomas and rather his wife
Jenny participated in the events of
January 6th and now what is likely going
before The Supreme Court is a judgment
as to whether an event that his wife
participated in that his wife has been
investigated by in the January 6
Committee in qualifies as an
Insurrection and Clarence Thomas's
decision on that one way or another and
overall the Court's decision on that
would directly implicate his wife and so
this is just one of the most classic
textbook conflicts of interest uh and it
would frankly be a scandal if he did not
recuse do you think what an what an
absolute farce and I did watch the
extended version of that he offers no
push back Anderson Cooper offers no push
back he is just a corporate mouthpiece
that is all he is you see what AOC did
there at first At first she tried to
imply that Clarence Thomas himself had
something to do the with the rection
then she backtracks says it's all about
Jenny Thomas again what she's referring
to is that these cases in Colorado and
where's the other one um and Maine where
they've removed Donald Trump from the
ballot for Insurrection something he
hasn't been convicted of that's going to
obviously those cases will work their
way up to the Supreme Court and I just
have no doubt that the Supreme Court is
going to do the right thing and reverse
them but she wants Clarence Thomas to
recuse himself from that because she
doesn't like Clarence Thomas because she
doesn't like an up black guy who doesn't
think the way she thinks let's put that
aside for moment uh the other sort of
strange story over the last couple days
uh and it's related to these people that
constantly lie about everything is that
our secretary of defense Lloyd Austin uh
he was MIA for about a week uh and well
we've got some info here from the daily
wire the story is just absolutely insane
Secretary of Defense Lloyd Austin
remained hospitalized on Sunday night
after being rushed to the hospital at
the start of the New Year After
experiencing severe pain as he recovered
late last month from an elective
procedure the Pentagon said in a
statement that Austin remained at the
Walter Reed National military Medical
Center but was recovering well and in
good spirits The Wall Street Journal
reported that Austin had an undisclosed
elective procedure on December 22nd
during scheduled leave and returned home
the following day on January 1st Austin
experienced severe pain and was rushed
to Walter read where he was admitted
into its Intensive Care Unit the report
said the report said that the White
House was not notified of the situation
because Austin chief Austin's Chief of
Staff uh Kelly maiman was simultaneously
out at the same time with the flu and
because chairman of the G Joint Chiefs
of Staff uh General CQ Brown was not
wasn't bound to tell the White House as
an as a subordinate advisory all right
so do you get what just happened here so
the guy has surgery we'll have more on
that in just a second he dips out they
don't tell the White House they don't
tell the white house because his number
two is on vacation the one after that
they're claiming there's some chain of
command thing just seems a little odd
you know you'd think the White House
might know if the head of the military
at the moment right the defense
secretary do you think that if he was
out for an afternoon that somebody might
need to know about that anyway Peter
Ducey over at Fox one of the few people
that I can call a journalist without you
using air quotes here he is asking White
House spokesman John Kirby how this
possibly happened and could they be
lying about someone else's health if
they've been lying about Lloyd Austin's
health and we'll get more to Lloyd
Austin's Health in just a sec why should
we believe anything that this
Administration tells us about anything
ever again I think we all recognize and
I think the Pentagon has
been very very honest with themselves
about uh the um the challenge to to to
credibility by what by what has
transpired here and by what and by
uh uh
how
how how hard it was for them to be fully
transparent with the American people I
think we all recognize that and
administration is going to go to Such
Great Lengths to keep secrets about the
defense secretary's Health how can
anybody be certain that the
administration would not go to the same
lengths to keep secret problems with
President Biden's help in the future if
if you could logically argue and you
can't but if you could logically argue
that the he's 81 years old wait wait a
second just give me a second here BB
I'll get there if if the administration
made some sort of Machiavellian effort
uh across the board to just to to keep
this from getting public then I think
your question has Merit and and
certainly is a fair one I don't think
it's a fair one because that's not what
happened here Peter what happened here
is the Secretary of Defense uh for
whatever reason I can't answer the
question why that information wasn't
shared it wasn't shared widely in the
department and it certainly wasn't
shared with the not it's not good it's
certainly not good which is why again we
want to learn from this we want to we
want to make sure that it doesn't happen
again all right there's just so much
nonsense there I mean the main question
that we all had in this room was what is
going on with that guy's shoulder pads I
mean he's making be Arthur proud right
like there's some Michael Scott level
shoulder pads there um also he's like I
can't how could I answer why the guy
wouldn't tell us what he was doing who
what do you think I am I'm the I'm the
White House Press Secretary I'm not
somebody that's supposed to know
something it's just absolutely absurd of
course the the broader point that we all
every sane person in America right now
has let's just say some slight uh
curiosity as it relates to Joe Biden's
Health right the stammering the
confusion the falling asleep the
wandering out into the forest like
there's a bunch of stuff that I think
legitimately we could ask about what
Kirby tries to do there is make it seem
like the only way you could really ask
about that is if it was some Mass
Machiavellian plan across the board
everybody knew it might be a pretty
small conspiracy it might only be a
conspiracy between Dr Joe Biden and
don't you forget she's a doctor and Joe
Biden's physician whoever is giving him
the drugs and they obviously are and a
couple other people I think it's
possible that John Kirby doesn't even
know what's going on but that doesn't
mean that nothing is going
on uh anyway here's the John Kirby's
counterpart when when Kirby's not
available as you know they Trot out
Karin Jean Pierre the diversity hire
black Les Ian and here she is explaining
a little bit more about this situation
and how Joe Biden knew nothing about it
when Jake Sullivan and then Jeff Zs and
then the president here that secretary
Austin's in the hospital didn't they ask
why is he in the hospital how did the
president not know until this morning
that it was cancer how did 5 days go
without knowing the something that we're
trying to find not give an answer I I
hear you but that is something that we
are going to get a sense of this process
right that's why they're going to do a
review that's why why the pentagon's
going to do a review oh well we're just
trying to figure it out we we we have no
idea oh did you catch that by the way so
yeah Lloyd awon has cancer now I wish
him well and hopefully the surgery went
well but do you think that the Secretary
of Defense in a situation that we're in
right now with everything going on in
the Middle East and constant
encroachment by China and I don't know
that Russia Ukraine thing and everything
else do you think that it might be uh
public knowledge important public
knowledge that the Secretary of Defense
has cancer and that if he's going to
under that now he could have cancer and
still be able to do do the job that is
certainly possible uh but do you think
it's odd that they did not inform the
president of the United States about
this the man then underwent surgery his
number two person was on vacation and
nobody told the administration and Karin
Jean Pierre well we don't know somebody
we'd have to figure out how somebody
something I don't know anything about
anything speaking of people who don't
know anything about anything Jen saki
who was the former White House Press
secretary before Jean kin Pierre and
John Kirby she's got a show on
propaganda mental institution MSNBC
right now and uh she had Nancy Pelosi on
and they uh were discussing what should
happen to Lloyd Austin after all of this
do you feel still feel confident in him
serving as Secretary of Defense well I'm
a big fan of of of the secretary I think
he's done a remarkable job as Secretary
of Defense He commands great respect and
fact I was going to give him a call this
past week about something and I thought
I'll just do it when I get back to DC
but um uh that's really something up to
the him and the president of the United
States because nobody knows better than
the Secretary of Defense and the
commander-in-chief this alcoholic woman
like the children the children um I was
going to give him a call that's what she
says I was going to give him a call you
know why she didn't give him a call
because he M he mysteriously disappeared
because he was in the hospital for
secret cancer surgery and didn't tell
anyone and he has not done an
extraordinary job look at what is going
on in the world right now we don't have
to go through the laundry list so the
point guys is how do we get out of this
mess how do we get out of a situation
where our media lies to us about
everything our late night comedians lie
to us about everything our politicians
lie to us the spokespeople lie to us
about everything and then a few of us
are spinning out there in the universe
going is there anything true is there
any way to assemble something good again
something real and tangible well yes I
do think there is a way to do it we'll
get to that at the end but I want to go
a little bit deeper in what happens when
people lie to us all the time so when
Donald Trump says I'm going to build a
wall and Deport people and he doesn't
then immigration gets worse when Joe
Biden says uh there is no problem at the
border and we know that there's a
problem then things start getting worse
now check this story out this is the
viral story of the day and I don't know
how much coverage it's going to get on
mainstream because it doesn't fit the
narrative this is
absolutely completely freaking bananas
at James Madison High School in Brooklyn
take a look at this will be remote why
because a group of 2,000 illegal aliens
are being transferred to New York City
and will be sleeping in the school's gym
Americans are being deprived of an
education to cater to illegals council
member Ena vernikov released a statement
blasting the decision that's from the
libs of Tik Tock account uh and now
let's just check out some of the video
These are illegal immigrants migrants
whatever you want to call them but they
are illegal here they are uh pouring
into this school and it's gymnasium in
Brooklyn last
night
[Music]
spee
there's so much here it's like it's just
incredible okay so first off the the
basic idea that we are now after
everything we know after the three years
of all of that covid we are
having kids in Brooklyn kicked out of
their own school to learn remotely and
we know that means basically not
learning so that 2,000 illegals can be
you know housed at this school in and of
itself is crazy these people should not
be in the country that is not to say
that those kids are not nice and cute
and everything else but they should not
be here by the way that school normally
has metal detectors at those doors for
the kids to walk through the normal
students from Brooklyn to walk through
the usual students somehow those medical
detectors disappeared as the illegal
migrants were walking their way through
um we well let's just show you a little
bit more from this uh I mean it's just
look at these there's supposed to be
metal detectors there they're not but
you have to have your normal students
walking through metal teers but look
these people again it's not to say any
of these people are mean or bad or
anything else but they are not supposed
to be here but
congratulations if you live in New York
City congratulations if you live in
Brooklyn congratulations if you live in
Chicago or LA or anywhere else decided
to become a sanctuary City you are going
to import all of these people and I know
you had the best of intentions and you
just wanted to be nice and then
congratulations your kids will be kicked
out of school your tax dollars will not
go to roads or for good education or
anything else it will go to destroy your
life and you will pay for it you will
sit there and shut up because you're a
good Democrat anyway Elon Musk uh saw
this video and he had this to say this
is what happens when you run out of
hotel rooms soon cities will run out of
schools to vacate then they will come
for your homes I mean that is a freaking
scary ass warning and I'll tell you
something I don't even know that I even
said this when we were leaving La one of
the main reasons so I left La obviously
after the failed recall and covid
lockdowns and everything else one of my
main concerns because we had absolutely
beautiful house it was up the hill a
little bit I I really thought we were
going to live there raise our family
there I thought we were going to be
there the rest of our lives we had just
moved in a year before had no intentions
we built up great studio all that had no
intentions of moving we were we were in
the valley off Ventura Avenue which sub
which just a year before had been
completely destroyed in the name of
Tolerance and Peace by the BLM and
antifa activists but anyway there were
all of these then vacant buildings
because nobody was going to work anymore
in Los Angeles and I said to David one
day as we were at the supermarket I was
like I have no doubt that one day all of
the illegals will be moving into all of
these empty vacant buildings and when
the illegals get there and there are no
jobs for them and they're not happy with
the services and everything else where
are the houses that they're going to be
breaking into to steal all the stuffff
oh those are the houses right up there
and that that was going to be our house
and that's partly why we got out there
so Elon Musk absolutely gets it you let
in all of these people you destroy all
the social services now you're letting
them take over freaking schools and when
because we already know they took over
the homeless shelters and then
eventually yes they will start taking
over people's houses too they will
literally just show up at your door kick
you out of the house and you think the
LA Police Department's going to do
anything you think the new NYPD is going
to do anything with when eight African
men that are 25 military Age come in and
they say they want to take over your
home yeah the police are going to do
anything they ain't going to do jack
and speaking of people that don't
want to do jack here's Democrat
Senator Chris Murphy from Connecticut uh
saying that the Democrats are just not
going to do anything about this I think
we are interested as Democrats in
providing the administration with tools
that will help better manage the Border
we are not interested in taking away
from the
administration tools that they use today
to help better manage the border and so
when we talk about this topic of parole
it is very important to understand that
it is used today as a way that the
administration is able to better manage
the flow in a planful way of individuals
to the Border
man these people are evil did you catch
the dystopian language did you catch the
1984 part of that we don't want to take
away the tools that he has to manage the
Border meaning not stop people from
coming in which is what he should be
doing we don't want to take away the
tool what's the tool the tool is the
parole the tool is you come here
illegally we have some sort of mechanism
you sign something we give you a phone
we ship you off to Chicago or to San
Diego we don't want to take that away
because that's how we're managing right
that's how we're managing the situation
so they want more of these illegals here
they are trying to destroy our country
there is an invasion I don't think this
makes me a tin foil hat conspiracy
theorist I'm just repeating what they
are saying I'm just cleaning up the
language he's saying well there's a
certain system in place the system gets
the people here then gets them into our
country we wouldn't want to stop him
from doing
that let's shift this over to uh the
Republican side because while Democrats
blow Republicans suck you guys all know
that and Donald Trump you may remember
Donald Trump uh said he was going to
build a wall he built about 50 miles of
it there's some people that say he built
about 500 Miles doesn't matter we've got
about 25 200 miles that need to be built
if it's ever going to happen the
Democrats didn't want to work with him I
don't put the blame all on him on that
uh he said he was going to kick a whole
bunch of people out he didn't do any of
that Obama actually kicked more people
out than Trump did but you may remember
this from back in October uh when Trump
actually admitted he said the quiet part
out loud that when he was saying Mexico
was going to pay for it it was just
complete BS he just made it up and here
he is admitting it so with all those
losers out there that say Trump never
got the you remember I used to say
Mexico will pay for the piece of the
wall I'll say what's going to happen
with they fight I say the wall gets
higher we all had a lot of fun but I
said Mexico will pay for a piece of the
wall well there was no legal instrument
to do all those losers who believed me
all I just said some stuff I say crazy
stuff there was no legal mechanism to
make that thing happen but I just said
that crazy crazy thing and of course it
didn't happen but I will do it again
this time do you guys believe
me so what do we what do we do here guys
we got a couple days before this Iowa
caucus I I have no doubt that I am uh
well no I want to word that a little bit
differently not have no doubt um it
seems to me if I was to believe the
polls and if I was to believe the
mainstream uh take on all of this uh
then this then this election has already
been decided right Trump's going to win
the Republican thing on a landslide and
then somehow even though the election
was stolen from him last time he will
beat Biden by such a high degree this
time they will not steal it again I
don't think that solves any problems I
don't think Trump solves any problems I
don't think Biden solves any problems I
think they are two sides of the same
coin um but I do think there is a better
choice and I think there's uh instead of
uh listening to someone someone who
tells you a loser while he's also
telling you that you shouldn't believe
his lies uh there are some people who
actually say things and actually go
ahead and do them I'm sick of Elites
imposing their Vision on open borders on
you and on us with them not having to
face the consequences of it so we
thought it was worth it to send 50
illegals to Martha's
Vineyard they said said they were a
sanctuary
City they claimed that nobody was
illegal and all are welcome but you know
what they did they deported them the
next day they called out the Army to
deport just 50 of them just think what's
going on at the border with our border I
think the choice is fairly clear right
we have this little moment where maybe
we can start fixing these things I do
not know that we will do it again as I
said yesterday if you live in Iowa right
now and you're watching this thing man
about 100,000 180,000 people caucused
last time in Iowa it's not a tremendous
amount of people you have influence you
could set the table for something to
really shift in this country right now
and I think most people regardless of
where you sit politically think
something is not right right the
Democrats think there's something really
wrong with the Republicans and the
Republicans think there's really
something wrong with the Democrats and
all of that stuff but we have this
little bit of a window right now a
couple days left to convince those
people in Iowa to do the right thing and
if they not what I believe to be the
right thing but vote for someone that
might get us out of some of this
nonsense because Trump is not getting us
out of this nonsense and Biden isn't
getting us out of this nonsense maybe
that other guy could maybe I think it's
worth a shot uh guys people of the
internet is live at one pm. today if you
want to join us for the postgame show
coming up in about 30 seconds Ruben
report. locals.com and we leave you with
Kathy hok and bacon and eggs and cheese
and what
concerned eyes of our healthcare workers
striving to heal the sick and comfort
the
dying and it's even the welcoming smile
of Bodega owners making a bacon egg and
cheese in the
morning you know they're good I've met
[Applause]
[Music]
them